PATRICK KLING: Hi, my
name is Patrick Kling,
and I'm an engineering manager
on the health care and life
sciences team here
at Google Cloud.
Our mission is to organize the
world's health care information
and to make it accessible,
secure, and useful,
to improve the health and health
care of people in communities
globally.
Today we're going to
talk about our offering
in the medical imaging space.
First we'll hear
from Omer Khawar,
who is the VP of
engineering at IDgital.
His company built a innovative
teleradiology solution
on top of Google Cloud Platform.
Afterwards, we'll
hear from my colleague
Sasha Sicular, who will be
walking us through the cloud
architecture of this system.
And then finally,
I'll be back up here,
and I'll be talking about
the platform underpinning
all of this, which is the
Cloud Health Care API.
And with that, I'll
hand it over to Omer.
OMER KHAWAR: Thanks, Patrick.
Hi, everybody.
Thanks for coming.
I know it's the last
day and people probably
have flights and things that
they want to get back to,
so I appreciate the
people that did come.
We have a lot of exciting
things to talk about today.
At IDgital, our mission
is to, essentially,
deliver better patient outcomes
through the application
of advanced technology.
When our founders sat down,
they looked at the entire health
care sector and determined that
the area of the industry that
was most ripe for
this kind of benefit
was, in fact, radiology, and
specifically, teleradiology.
So they thought
about the problems
that they were trying to solve.
There are over
35,000 radiologists.
Less than 3% of
them are networked.
There's no common platform
and a decided lack
of technological advancement.
This market is very large.
It's $5 billion.
But it's a highly
fragmented mix of solutions.
And so what we're running
into is essentially
two major areas of challenge.
In the market itself, we've got
radiologist burnout happening.
And there's a couple of factors
that are feeding into this.
One is that
radiologists are being
asked to read more and more,
so the volumes are increasing.
Also, radiologists are
being asked to do it faster.
Oftentimes, there are
patient expectations.
You know, I'd like
my reading back fast.
There are also clinical
concerns if there
are emergent indications
that things need
to be turned around rapidly.
So while the volume's
going up and people
are asked to do
their work faster,
the technology hasn't
been able to keep up.
In addition, another
trend that's worrying
is that coming out of
medical programs we're
having fewer and fewer people
actually opt to do radiology.
So all these factors
are driving radiologists
individually to try to do a lot,
lot more on the same platforms
and systems that they've
been using for decades.
We looked at some market surveys
and found that satisfaction
amongst the users-- and
user is the radiologist--
is down at the 40% level.
And for a $5 billion market
to be down that low--
and just to be clear,
that 40% satisfaction
is with any of the
solutions that exist.
It wasn't their
particular solution.
So they're essentially
saying there's nothing there
that really helps me execute
my work rapidly and achieve
those patient outcomes
that we're looking for.
And finally, with the trend in
fewer and fewer radiologists
and the increasing
cost of health care
that everybody is
aware of, we're
finding that we get very
poor rural coverage.
And institutionally,
also, there are
challenges in delivering
radiological care.
On the technology side,
we've got a lot of problems.
We've got cumbersome
data exchange.
So with any technology
that has been around
for a few decades,
what we're finding is
we've got a lot of
different systems.
They all speak a
little bit differently,
and so we've got all of these
point-to-point integrations
going on.
And that's in the
radiology workflow.
So from end to
end, you know, they
could touch four or
five different systems
provided by four or
five different vendors.
And as those vendors have
software that gets released,
we essentially have problems
in those integrations.
That's leading to
low reliability.
So it is not
uncommon-- and people
that are not in the field
may be shocked by this--
but it's not uncommon
for radiologists
to essentially show up to
work and not be able to work.
Their platform that allows
them to do teleradiology
just is not available
for hours at a time.
And finally, low innovation--
so I mentioned that before.
With the legacy systems that
are in place and the technology
that exists, what
we're finding is
it's very hard to get some of
the cutting edge technology,
specifically machine
learning models
and artificial
intelligence to be applied.
People are working very hard--
some of you are in the
room-- on these technologies.
And they're running
into real challenges
in delivering that into
the workflow for radiology.
I mean, I was talking to one
vendor that has to actually--
I mean, they're a team
of data scientists,
and they have to take the VMs
and put them in sites in order
to deliver that.
This is really-- these high road
blocks are causing people just
to not to use the technology.
And then finally, scalability--
so all of the things I talked
about from a fragmentation
perspective, from a
technology perspective,
are leading to an
inability to scale
any of the individual solutions
that are on the market
today, across the country.
So our solution--
so what we looked at
was to create a cloud native,
zero footprint teleradiology
solution.
The entire solution is built on
the cloud, including the DICOM
store.
So for those of you
not in the industry,
that's essentially the images
from the various modalities.
So those are on the cloud,
which is, believe it or not,
a significant step.
There's an embedded
DICOM viewer,
so that also is in the cloud.
And so that's important to
reduce the multiple vendor
approach that
currently exists today.
And then both RIS
and PACS capabilities
are built into the platform.
From a machine learning and AI
support perspective, you know,
the step one was to
create a platform
and then start to
drive in the capability
to add machine learning and
AI from cloud solutions that
exist today.
Embedded voice support is
an important work enabler
for radiologists.
And then streamlined
integration with facilities--
so those of you that
don't work in the space
may not understand how difficult
it is to actually connect
to facilities, whether that's
a hospital or an urgent care
center in some rural area.
But after we went live,
as VP of engineering,
those are all my problems.
And so it was great to get some
of the experience on our team,
you know, decades of experience,
doing this at the beginning,
so that we could build into
our solution capabilities that
actually make that faster.
It seems like the
simplest thing to do,
but it's actually been the
hardest to achieve in practice.
So now I'll talk about
the platform itself.
So those capabilities
can be broken down
into technical building blocks.
Later on, we'll go
through this in detail.
So I'm not going to spend too
much time on this slide going
through every bullet.
But I do think it's
important to kind of have
some context for the
capabilities that are there.
Data ingest-- so as I said,
many, many, many points.
This is all HIPAA data.
So it contains
patient information.
The images themselves
need to be secure.
So we needed to make sure it
was both secure and scalable,
scalable to thousands of points.
And so you'll see that in
our solution today, later on.
The platform itself--
so this, essentially,
is the work management.
It's the workhorse
of the platform.
And that's doing all of the
management of the work that's
coming in, assigning that
out to radiologists, managing
access, all of those things that
you would expect from a work
manager.
This is also where we
would introduce clinical,
AI based decision making.
The image viewer-- it's
already on the cloud.
Our images are in the cloud.
We have very low
latency in image fetch,
which again, is
a challenge based
on what I've described today.
And messaging-- so again,
we'll talk about this in detail
why we went this
route, but it was
important to have the
scalability within the system
to pass information
back and forth.
And mobile-- so I
think I referred
to earlier kind of
a lack of access
from an institutional
perspective.
So we made a mobile tool set
that allows, essentially,
mobile radiology to be enabled.
Essentially, these are
technicians that drive around
with a mobile unit, and
they can visit institutions
such as jails or hospitals,
elder care centers,
and our platform enables that
workflow also, seamlessly.
And finally, machine learning--
so that's really, I think-- the
point of making a new platform
is to enable that.
And we'll talk in detail
about how we did that
and what the capabilities
are to essentially create
that continuous
loop of learning.
And then underneath
this all, a data store.
So it was important that
the data be very close
to the application.
The latency that
users experience
today is very much
related to where
the data is, where
are the images,
where is the patient data.
And so it was very
important to bring that
close and on the same platform.
So why did we pick
Google for this solution?
Well, as you can see
on the left side,
all cloud services provide
a set of capabilities.
And so what distinguished
Google for us was really
that they had created and were
in alpha with a HIPAA compliant
data store.
And that was the
crux of the decision.
Also, the seamless
scalability that we
get with Kubernetes,
multi-region networking,
and then the rapid ML tools that
some of you have seen today,
and additions to those that were
announced at the conference.
So what does that mean from
an engineering perspective?
Well, it meant that I
could work with our design
teams, our SMEs in the
space, and essentially
use these tool sets and
accelerate the delivery
of the platform itself.
I don't need to sit there
and redesign everything
from scratch.
My engineers don't need to go
in and make all of these things.
I can leverage the services and
capabilities that Google has,
and later on we'll talk about
specifically which ones.
So what did we learn
working with Google?
Well, we found them to
be a very active partner.
As we went and
designed our solution,
there was very much a
conversation with them
about the approach
we would take,
how we would solve various
problems we ran into,
and I can't speak enough
about the health care team.
They were awesome
throughout the process.
In addition, we worked with
Zazmic, our engineering
partner, and they were critical,
too, in getting to market fast.
So again, some of
the cloud services
I mentioned that accelerated
our time to market--
and we'll go through
those in detail.
So technical lessons learned--
going through this process
of making this platform
from scratch,
cloud native, there
were a couple of things
we learned that are
pertinent in health care.
So number one, resource
matching was a key activity.
So what do I mean by that?
Essentially, as we
found these pieces
of data coming from
various sources,
getting that data associated
with both the patient
and the order that was
going on was critical,
and to be able to
do that at scale.
So we're talking
petabytes of information
that needs to hook together
and be related at the point
that the radiology is trying
to perform their tasks.
Association of DICOM
based studies with orders
has many edge cases.
So those of you that have
tried to use this standard
will understand the
standard is not standard.
And every vendor has
interpreted it their way.
And then finally, scaling--
we needed to scale.
We needed to scale fast.
And we needed to scale without
affecting our production
clients.
So we solve this in the
first case with microservices
in Pub/Sub, and
in the second case
by introducing and accommodating
the flexibility that
exists in DICOM, and
on the third with GKE.
And we're looking at
Istio and Service Mesh.
There was an announcement at
the conference on Service Mesh
also that we're
very interested in.
So we'll continue to work with
Google and with our engineering
partners to achieve those.
So next, Sasha is going
to come up and talk
about the architecture
in detail.
SASHA SICULAR: Thank you, Omer.
Appreciate everybody being here.
I'm very grateful
to be on this stage
and talking to you all about
this very interesting solution.
A little bit about myself--
before joining Google, I was
director of medical informatics
at Columbia University for many,
many, many years, many more
years than I'd like to admit.
And it's from that
background and learning
that I have an
appreciation for many
of these technical challenges
that organizations are trying
to solve, large and
small, ultimately to drive
better patient outcomes.
So what we're going
to do today is
talk through the
specific architecture
that we put in
place with IDgital
to help facilitate this zero
on prem footprint, entirely
cloud-based solution.
I'll just highlight a couple
of the steps right now.
Some of the key things
that I think everybody
should be focused on--
networking.
So networking is critically
important, of course.
As soon as you start talking
about moving to the cloud,
how are you going
to facilitate that?
So the network connectivity
is absolutely critical.
From that, we moved
deeper into the stack.
We talk about how Google
Cloud Platform organizes
its internal structures around
the concept of a project.
MLLP and DICOM, those are
two critical legacy protocols
that are ubiquitous in
the health care space,
and any organization looking to
move into this kind of method
of working in the cloud
needs to understand
the limitations of
both MLLP and DICOM
and how you can overcome
those limitations.
And we'll talk about that
in a little bit more detail.
From there, I want to point out,
obviously, the health care API.
The health care API is
really pivotal and central
to the entire conversation
of the architecture, what
it allows you to do, the kind
of capabilities it provides,
the kind of systems and services
you can build around it.
And then ultimately,
the health care
API will go into
even further detail
with Patrick, when he
speaks in the third act.
You know, Omer picked up
on something very quickly,
which was, I like to think
of it as liberating data.
So right now, to facilitate
day-to-day transactional
operations between
providers and patients,
those data systems are siloed.
They're isolated within
the on prem environment.
As we move into the future,
the question becomes,
how do we leverage that data
to provide better service?
Again, ultimately driving
better patient outcomes,
servicing more patients,
and really meeting
the challenges that all
organizations are facing today
in health care.
So by bringing the
data to the cloud
you get to take advantage of
all kinds of functionality
that's present in the cloud.
In particular, we'll
talk about BigQuery.
Underpinning the whole exercise,
of course, is security.
How do you ensure that
you are in compliance
with very stringent
HIPPA regulation regime?
So obviously, HIPPA is the
law of the land in the United
States.
Of course, we have
global presence.
So we'll talk about HIPPA today,
but this same conversation
plays internationally.
All kinds of jurisdictions are
introducing data protection
related regulation, in general
and also in health care.
So as an organization
that's looking
to take advantage of these
products and functionalities,
you obviously need to
make sure that you're
doing it in a very secure
and regulated fashion.
So let's talk about the
network connectivity.
What are we trying to
do here, ultimately?
We're looking to bring
data from where it's
being generated into the cloud.
And in order to
do that, you have
to have good network
connectivity.
If you think about
teleradiology,
the way that those providers
access this information
is that they have to get
that information from where
it's stored.
And traditionally,
that information
is stored on premises
where it's been generated.
So think about all of the
network connectivity issues
that a specific physical
facility may have.
Now let's turn it
around and think
about what the networking
opportunities and capabilities
are of Google.
So we have a major, major
networking presence globally,
with tremendous options
up and down the stack,
specifically dedicated
to networking.
Particularly, in
this solution, we're
looking at our
cloud VPN solution.
And this is what
really enables you
to do a fully zero
footprint installation.
Ultimately, the key thing
that the physical facility
needs to enable is
the VPN termination.
If they can enable that VPN
termination in their networking
stack connected to its
endpoint in the cloud,
that's basically
all you have to do.
Yes, there are other solutions.
You can look at various
interconnect solutions
for higher degrees of bandwidth.
You can look at even point
to point secure tunnel.
Those are a little bit
higher up the stack.
You go from zero footprint
to maybe 99% no footprint.
So cloud VPN was really
are our first intent
and our first interest to
facilitate this technology.
The key consideration
here is that the VPN
will route the traffic to
the appropriate IP address.
Not just externally,
but also internally.
As we continue the conversation
we look at Kubernetes,
et cetera, we'll
see how all those IP
considerations come into play.
Project-- so I spent
a little bit of time
earlier talking about this.
In Google Cloud Platform,
one of the major areas
of abstraction in the system
is what we call the project.
And for any of you who have
worked with Google Cloud
Platform previously, you'll
be familiar with this concept.
The project is where you
put all the things, so all
of your networking resources,
all of your virtual machines,
your Kubernetes clusters,
et cetera, et cetera.
They all exist
inside of projects.
And why should we
consider projects
as a major boundary
for the architecture
of the application?
Data isolation-- obviously, as
a technical services provider,
IDgital is looking to
onboard many, many customers.
We want to ensure that their
data is completely isolated
from any of the other customers
in the system, specifically
the hard data, the
DICOM images themselves.
Also, the project is
where billing happens.
So when you create
a project, you
create an associated
billing account,
and all of the resources
and consumption
of those resources
within that project
are then charged into
that billing account.
So for an organization
that's looking
to onboard many,
many customers, you
want to have a very,
very close accounting
of what those underlying
resources are costing.
So by isolating at
the project level,
you're able to have a very,
very fine grained control
or insight into what
all of the resources
are costing on a customer
by customer basis.
Again, due to the
fact that the project
is the kind of base
level of abstraction,
all of the things that are
in the project, health care
API, Google Cloud buckets,
Google Cloud Storage
buckets, virtual
machines, allocation
of reserved external IP
addresses, et cetera,
et cetera, all of
those items have
quotas associated with them.
So quota management is how
it is handled on a project
by project basis.
So again, this is how
you are able to isolate
various customers
from clobbering
other customers, et
cetera, et cetera.
And they maintain their
entire individual ecosystem.
And then finally, security.
Projects, again, not
just data isolation,
but access to projects
are controlled
via GCPIM, which is identity
and access management,
and you can very,
very fine grained
control over which systems,
which people, which accounts,
which services can access all
the things within the project.
So for this particular
implementation use
case with IDgital, we have
many projects that play here.
We have production,
development, demo,
where IDgital is able to spin up
a completely identified system
and demo it to prospective
customers, et cetera.
What you'll see is,
and we'll talk about it
in particular, logging.
Again, Cloud Audit
logging, Stackdriver,
these are all very
important pieces
of the overall conversation, and
what we in health care and life
sciences group
within Google Cloud
recommend as a
HIPAA best practice.
All of the projects, all
of the independent projects
in the system, can outbound
their logs to a audit
and logging dedicated
project that
can be staffed specifically
by a compliance
organization, separate
group of people, no bleed,
anything like that.
A project per customer--
talked about that a little bit.
And finally, all of these
pieces can be automated
and this is one of the
pieces of the word scale.
How do you scale the
solution to accommodate,
you know, hopefully you're
going to do good business.
You want to accommodate
lots and lots of customers.
How do you, as an
organization, enable
the onboarding of all
of these customers,
and managing of all
of these scenarios?
It has to be automated.
So everything we're
going to talk about today
can be automated
through Cloud Deployment
Manager, G Cloud, kube control.
Kubernetes-- Kubernetes
is kind of the base
layer of scalable
abstraction from
a computational perspective.
In this particular
use case calls
for using Kubernetes to
scale both the MLLP and DICOM
adapters and the application
specific services.
The key part here
is the networking.
So the Kubernetes cluster itself
controls the ingress networking
from your external
on prem customers
to their specific MLLP
and DICOM adapters.
Of course, everything in
the Kubernetes cluster
is connected to the entire
logging infrastructure.
And what Kubernetes
really brings to the table
is, as I said, the ability
to scale the computation.
But on which dimension
do you scale?
How do you determine
when you should scale?
There is new developments,
of course, always coming,
new developments.
So GKE enables you to
scale on custom metrics.
So for example, MLLP is
lightweight from a data
perspective.
Its high message volume.
DICOM is a little bit heavier
because it's the actual image.
So they have different
scaling dimensions,
and by integrating with
custom metrics for scaling,
they can scale independently.
MLLP and DICOM adapters--
this is really a lot of the
meat of the architecture.
Google publishes open source,
MLLP and DICOM adapters.
And the way that you
should think about them
is as a bridge.
On one side, they receive
legacy MLLP and DICOM protocol
communication.
On the other side, they egress
health care API protocol.
So this is the real
workhorse here.
This is what enables
you to bridge
the legacy on prem environment,
the ubiquitous presence
of these protocols, and
virtually all hospital oriented
systems around the world to
your cloud-based solution.
And again, as I
mentioned, these services
are exposed via private internal
load balancer IP addresses.
Those addresses in turn
are routed through the VPN.
The Kubernetes cluster
basically plays double duty.
In addition to hosting the
MLLP and DICOM adapters,
we're also hosting services.
So the classic service oriented
architecture, microservices,
pulling together a specific
set of business logic
to accommodate a
particular business
task into a specific process.
And these processes
do various things.
For example in this use
case, we're creating order.
So as messages come
into the system,
they emit notifications
into Cloud Pub/Sub.
We'll talk more about
that in particular.
And these services listen
for those notifications.
And when they get
those notifications,
they do specific things.
So for example, they might
listen for a DICOM message
and then create the
associated ORM HL7 message.
They might listen for
the ORM HL7 message
and then create an order in
the transactional Cloud SQL
database in the IDgital
application itself.
Resource matching-- Omer
mentioned that briefly.
How do you match an HL7
message to its DICOM study?
How do you do all these things?
And then finally billing--
we highlight billing
as well, of course.
Major component of the system.
You want to think about
how those bills then
need to be delivered
to those organizations.
Healthcare API.
All kinds of interesting
things happening here
that Patrick will talk
about in specific detail.
But some of the
things that I wanted
to highlight in
particular for this use
case and implementation are the
data store architecture design.
So we have highlighted
here in the architecture
three different data stores.
One for ORMs and ORUs, so
that's requests for reports
and then the report reply.
DFTs, Detailed Financial
Transaction HL7 messages.
And then, of course,
DICOM messages.
So ORM and ORU are
in one data store.
DFTs are in another data store.
DICOMs are in their
own data store,
and we had an interesting design
decision to determine, well,
do we need one for real-time
and do we need one for priors?
Or for those not
in the business,
the archive of all of the
previous images that were done.
And due to how different
microservices--
we've architected various
microservices in the system--
we decided to put them all
together in one DICOM store.
Each of those data
stores then output
into their own
Cloud Pub/Sub topic,
and these topics of
course are critical.
This is where the
microservices listen
for various pieces
of information, put
in new pieces of
information, and there
are many ways to interact
with these Pub/Sub stores.
The takeaway for these is that
it's completely integrated,
so this is completely managed
by Google Cloud Platform.
There's all kinds
of capabilities
to interact with the queues,
to ACK or acknowledge messages
from the queue, or not
acknowledge messages
from the queue, ensuring
that they get picked up
at a later date.
Configurable retention.
The messages stay around
until they're processed,
et cetera, et cetera.
BigQuery.
This is a really interesting
part of the conversation,
and I spoke a little bit
about it at the intro.
Omer mentioned it.
Going to the cloud
shouldn't be an apples
to apples conversation.
It should be an apples to
fruit basket conversation.
You get all the things
because going into the cloud
unlocks all of the other
opportunities in the cloud.
In particular here we're
highlighting BigQuery.
So BigQuery is Google's
data warehouse system.
And once you get
data into BigQuery
you can do all kinds
of interesting things.
You can enable analytics.
You can enable more
advanced analytics we
love to call machine learning.
Sprinkle a little bit of
machine learning on everything
and everything's better.
But you've got to get
the data there first.
It has to get there.
The way that we've designed
the Healthcare API is that it
easily can export data
into BigQuery and cannot
underestimate easy.
Easy is incredibly important.
BigQuery's got all the goodies.
It's scalable.
It's fully managed.
Auditable, again, integrates
with external reporting tools,
like Looker and our Data
Studio, Tableau, accessible
via standard ANSI SQL.
So for those of you in the
audience who have a SQL
background this is fantastic.
eUnity viewer.
The eUnity viewer is
the DICOM viewer itself.
So this is a commercially
available product
from another company.
It integrates directly
with the Healthcare API.
It's specifically designed
to have various pieces
of functionality segmented.
So we have a front
end web application.
We have a data cache proxy.
We also have a
computational engine
that just executes
3D volume metrics.
And the key takeaway
here is that because it's
delineated you can execute
specific fine-grained access
controls.
The IDgital application itself
runs it in its own project
and it has many
different components
running in virtual
machines, using Cloud SQL,
storing all this data in
the transactional database.
It has its own access
control for front end users,
and ultimately,
again, is separated
from the services that access
various parts of the system.
So this is security
isolation and reducing
that footprint that
might cause challenges
from a security perspective.
We talked a lot
about the logging.
Separate project for logging.
Specifically, an
opportunity to segment
all logs and make them only
available to your compliance
organization.
Again, HIPPA best practice.
Isolation, ability to transfer
these logs into BigQuery
similar to the clinical data.
Do all kinds of advanced
analytics, anomaly detections.
Do we have problems?
Are the wrong people accessing
this data, et cetera,
et cetera?
Finally, because this
system is so flexible,
you have the opportunity to send
your data to various billing
providers, and the
billing providers,
of course like everybody else,
don't really share standards.
So you need to be able to
speak to the specific billing
provider that your customer
has a contract with.
And what are their capabilities?
Native APIs, being able
to send specific billing
DFTs, the batching, CSVs.
This again ties into the
microservice architecture.
Being able to create the right
materialization of your billing
log and get that sent to the
billing provider in the way
that they can consume it.
And again, the system
here is delineated
within its own
microservice architecture.
So with that, just
a quick recap.
This was a really
very fast walkthrough
of a complete end-to-end
architecture with zero
on prem footprint.
Completely in the cloud.
Everything is operating the
cloud using many different GCP
pieces of functionality.
Everything is automated.
Everything I talked about
here can be automated,
and we're working
continuously to do
that to create the automation
scripts with IDgital Cloud
Deployment Manager, G
Cloud, Kube control.
Finally, we leverage
many different components
of the cloud.
So it's not just Healthcare API.
You got to bring all the
other pieces together--
networking, security, BigQuery.
And ultimately
the Healthcare API
itself is storing this very
critical health care data.
And with that I want to pass
the baton to my colleague
Patrick, who will tell us
more about the Healthcare API.
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICK KLING: Thank you, Sasha.
Thank you, Sasha.
So what is the Healthcare API?
We've heard a lot about it
in Sasha's architecture.
So fundamentally, the
way we think of it
is it's a managed scalable and
secure platform for your health
care data.
So we built the Healthcare
API to be interoperable,
so that means it can talk
to your existing systems
in the health care space.
And it also supports
industry standards
that we encounter in
the health care space.
We've designed it to be
developer friendly and easy
to use for our customers.
Of course, security
and compliance
are very important concerns
in the health care area,
so we built the Healthcare
API with robust security
and compliance features in mind.
Finally, the Healthcare
API is designed
to allow customers to really
unlock the value of the data
that they store in it.
For example, this is
done by integrating
with powerful analytics and
machine learning solutions.
So as we heard
earlier in the talk,
most customers in
the health care space
today have data stored in a
variety of different on prem
systems.
Typically those are fairly
fragmented or siloed.
So you'll have
separate data systems
for different types of data,
different systems maybe
for different
geographical locations.
You might have different systems
in different parts of a health
care organization.
And it's very difficult
for data to travel from one
of those systems to another.
So what we've done
with the Healthcare API
is we are aiming to
allow our customers
to bring all their data
together in a single place.
The way we've done
that is by integrating
with existing systems.
So this includes
packs and VNA systems.
Those are systems that customers
use to manage their imaging
data today.
And also integrating
with EHR systems,
which have structured
health care records.
We heard a little bit
about this earlier.
We support natively a number
of the most common formats
that we encounter in
the health care area.
So on the imaging side
this is primarily DICOM.
So DICOM is a format for
storing medical images and also
the metadata pertaining
to those images.
On the electronic health records
side, we support FHIR and HL7.
We heard a little bit
about the adapters also.
So these are some
open source components
that we've put out
there to make it easier
to interact with what we
think of as the legacy
protocols of exchanging those
types of data, notably DICOM
[INAUDIBLE] as well as MLLP.
So what do you mean when
we say the Healthcare
API is developer friendly?
Well, like most GCP APIs
it's a modern RESTful API
built on top of HTTPS and gRPC.
So the goal for us really was to
allow customers and developers
to focus on their business
logic while Google would worry
about things like backups,
configuring VMs, and setting up
databases.
The Healthcare API is
a fully serverless API,
so that means all scaling
and serving infrastructure
is all handled by
Google's infrastructure.
We integrated the Healthcare
API with Google Cloud console,
so this provides our customers
with a graphical user interface
for easily managing the
resources stored in the API.
Cloud Pub/Sub I think we heard
about it in Sasha's diagrams.
This is just a very
powerful, versatile mechanism
for plugging in any kind
of custom processing logic
into your health care workflow.
So we think of it as
almost the Swiss army knife
of integrating with our API.
Health care data is probably
one of the most sensitive types
of data out there, and
I'm sure most of you
will know that privacy is
heavily regulated in the health
care space.
So that's why we designed
the Healthcare API
from the ground up with a
very robust set of security
and compliance features
built right in.
Like all of Google
Cloud, the Healthcare API
is built on top of Google's
trusted infrastructure,
so it benefits from the
same multilayered security.
We have built in
fine-grained access controls,
so this allows customers
to use Cloud IAM
and specify exactly
who gets access to what
parts of their data.
And then they can also
go to Cloud Audit Logging
where they can verify who
is actually looking at what
and maybe detect any anomalies
that might have occurred.
HIPPA compliance is
table stakes when
handling health care data with
personal information in it.
So we built the Healthcare API
to support HIPPA compliance,
and we regularly
sign BAA agreements
with our customers
in this space, which
is a legal requirement.
We have also built the
Healthcare API to support data
locality.
So what this means is a customer
can specify where in the world
they want their
data to be stored.
This is important for
health care customers
in many jurisdictions
where there
are data residency requirements
that they have to comply with.
One of the key benefits of
using the Cloud Healthcare API
is that it allows customers
to bring all their health
data from where it resides
today and assemble it
in a single place where they can
reason about it holistically.
And finally, we also
have some mechanisms
in the Cloud Healthcare
API that allows customers
to then take those models
and actually deploy them
into a clinical workflow.
So for the remainder
of the talk,
I'd like to walk you through
three key scenarios or three
key use cases that
we've encountered
when working in this space.
So first of all,
I'd like to describe
how we can support research
and clinical viewing
of medical images using
the Cloud Healthcare API.
Next, I'll talk a little
bit about high performance
analytics using BigQuery.
And finally, I'll get
into machine learning
and how to train and
deploy models there.
So the Healthcare API
is a flexible platform
for viewing medical
imaging data.
Images can be ingested
into the Healthcare API
either from a PACS
system directly--
so this is kind
of similar to what
we saw in some of the
architecture diagrams
previously where we have images
traveling from an on prem PACS
and into the
Healthcare API maybe
using one of our adapters.
But we also support bulk import
from Google Cloud Storage.
And the nice thing about
the bulk import piece
is that it actually enables
customers to use things
like the Transfer Appliance.
So this is a tool
that allows customers
to do bulk loads of very
large amounts of data
that would maybe take a
very long time to send over
the network.
With the Transfer
Appliance, we can
bypass that and get it into the
Healthcare API more quickly.
We have then worked with
a number of partners
to build Healthcare API support
into medical imaging viewers.
So we already heard about
one of them, eUnity.
There is another
commercial viewer, IMS,
that's also supporting
the Cloud Healthcare API.
But we've also worked with a
number of open source projects.
So WEASIS and OHIF are a
couple of open source viewers
that also can talk to the
Healthcare API directly.
So for all of these they can
fetch the images directly
from the API, so it's a truly
serverless, end-to-end viewing
experience.
On the analytic
side of the story,
we rely heavily on BigQuery.
So BigQuery is Google's
petabyte scale, high performance
analytics engine.
It's something we
built originally
for our own internal
use at Google
to understand user behavior
on some of our consumer
facing products.
So via the Cloud
Healthcare API, we're
making this powerful tool
available to our customers
in the health care space
by allowing customers
to load their health
data into BigQuery.
Once their data
is in BigQuery, it
becomes very easy to join across
different data modalities,
join in additional data sets,
maybe join in some public data
sets.
We have some of those
available, like the RxNorm data
set, which is a
prescription drug database.
So you can maybe combine
your health care records
data, your imaging metadata,
and maybe some genomics data,
and then you can really
start to reason about those.
So there is a nearly endless
lists of use cases for this,
so I'm highlighting
three of them here.
So we've got some customers
that are using BigQuery
to identify and select cohorts
to include in research studies.
So select a list of
patients, for instance,
and then maybe
materialize their data,
deidentify it, and hand
it over to researchers.
We've also seen customers using
BigQuery for clinical decision
support.
So this is an example
where maybe we
want to find similar
patients to the one
that a provider is
currently looking at.
And finally, because
BigQuery is fast
it allows fast
turnaround on queries.
So it's a very useful
tool for iterating
on things like quality
and performance metrics,
where we want to start measuring
things in the health care
enterprise that
are very hard to do
in the existing on prem silos.
Finally, let's talk a little
bit about machine learning.
So one of the key benefits
of the Cloud Healthcare API
is that it can bring your health
care data to advanced machine
learning solutions.
So these machine
learning solutions,
again, can take advantage of
the full spectrum of health care
data--
health care records,
imaging data, genomics data,
you name it.
We integrate with some
powerful labeling tools.
So those can be
used by customers
to curate high quality training
data sets for their machine
learning use cases.
And then we can make
those data and labels
available to a Cloud
Machine Learning Engine
and AutoML, which are some of
the advanced machine learning
tools built into
Google Cloud Platform.
So Cloud Machine
Learning Engine you
can think of it as our
hosted version of TensorFlow.
So this is something that allows
serverless training of machine
learning models.
AutoML is a tool that's
specialized for customers that
may not have a lot of
data science or machine
learning expertise
at their disposal.
And it's a powerful tool that
can allow customers to train
models even in those contexts.
Finally, once a customer
ha trained a model,
the Healthcare API can
also help them deploy
this model back
into their workflow.
So for example, if
I have a model that
can help me understand
an x-ray image,
I can use the Cloud Healthcare
API to bring the prediction
from that model back into
the existing PACS viewer
so a radiologist
can view the model
prediction alongside the images
when they're doing their read.
So one thing I would
like to announce
is that the Cloud Healthcare
API as of last week
is actually available
in public beta,
so this means it's
something that's
now available to all Google
Cloud customers to use.
We also have some
public imaging data
sets available hosted on the
Cloud Healthcare API already,
so this can be a
great place for you
to start playing with some
of our viewer integrations
and maybe start trying
out some of the tools
that we discussed today.
So notable we have the NIH
chest x-ray data set on there,
and we also have the cancer
imaging archive on there.
All right.
So with that, I'd like to thank
you all for your attention.
[MUSIC PLAYING]